would you date a full-time youtuber
full-time youtuber for a bit that sounds
like an experience
for a bit i'll waste this time for a
little bit yeah i would like yeah that
sounds like you wouldn't marry a
youtuber what does your husband do
youtuber oh i don't think i don't think
like that i don't think like oh it's a
it's it's uh a shame to be the title
it's not about the title it's about the
experience okay and being with a
youtuber means that like everything is
on camera all the time and that your
life is up for display and that i don't
like okay how about you i would if i
resonated with the things that he was
doing like if i can be involved in what
he's doing and we can build together
mm-hmm
by the way how important is your man's
career
like
what he does yeah exactly how important
is that as a to a woman i mean very
important like i always thought i wanted
to date a businessman right and then
when i started hanging around
businessmen i'm like i can't with them
being on the phone 24 7. like if we're
at dinner like we need to sit down and
have a conversation i don't need you
leaving every five seconds stuck on the
phone okay so for me it's not about his
career but his relationship to it
if he is like somebody who's very
passionate about what they do like i
like that because it's energy and
somebody who's getting up and happy to
do what they do but if your career is
draining you that permeates into the
relationship what if he's so passionate
about it that it's his priority and it's
kind of just overstepping you to the
point like you're too passionate about
that not enough about me um i don't i
think that p everybody's always
searching for balance all the time it's
hard to have a passion and still have
room for the people in your life as well
so i wouldn't discredit it i'd be like
this is something we got to work on but
i'm also a super passionate person would
you rather date a guy
uh who makes a good money good income
but has zero social cred has zero social
media he's like a nobody to the world
but he does well for himself or
major influencer everybody knows this
person social clout but ain't making no
money
for them number one number one i didn't
ask you david i'm asking the ladies what
men are you doing go ahead amber who
would you rather adam for sure the off
the radar guy
for sure off the radar off the radar
makes money folds laundry does your
thing yeah you don't care about his
social media jenny you have a different
opinion off the radar off the road we
hate when men have social so is it not a
turn-on it's not it's it's not that it's
not a turnout or it is turn on it's just
the things that it comes with like
people think they want to be famous and
so they see what fame comes with and
like going outside in a restaurant you
can't have dinner because people are
constantly taking pictures of you like
that's annoying as
blank you can curse yourself
amber but by the way speaking of uh
social media you two i've heard you do a
joke
about only fans about like your calves
or something yeah enlighten us what's
that um it's just me by the way amber is
a as a dancing comedian i am because i'm
professional dancer turned comedian
because i love being broke um
i love it so much i'm so good at it uh
talking about ways i could make money
there are lots of ways as women that we
can make money by the way and like i
don't know how you're going to raise
daughters to be like hey i know people
are going to want to pay you to sell
your body sell your fart sell your
underwear online it's true yeah is that
a thing yeah the girl who made 50 000
selling her farts no in a jar to be
honest with you in a jar
it would be on the tv for sure she made
fifty thousand dollars in a week selling
her farts in a jar to be honest with you
i didn't even know that girls farted
we don't it's a lie anyway my point is i
don't know how you raise his daughter to
be like your your morals are more
important than money so what did you
decide to do
anyway my point is i have calves that
are i guess pretty muscular i don't know
if you can see them yeah those are some
those are some thick-ass
cows three c's i'm thick and guys
message me on instagram all the time to
send them pictures for money and videos
of my calves just my calves nothing else
just the legs amber let me be your agent
i swear to god there's no shame in the
game of just being like boom captain can
i i mean be a calf model like that's if
i can make money i'll do it have you
ever considered it just i have sent it
of course
of course i sent a picture it was like
80 bucks the fastest 80 bucks i've ever
made yeah amber go down that path
but like you'll be the richest it's just
so silly guys i just feel so silly
they're like can you flare them out for
me you really only have to take one
picture and send it that's it
to everyone else okay it becomes weirder
they start getting weirder than it's
never just that then they're like can
you do this can you do that can you
wiggle more
don't you wiggle them around you jump on
the ground can you wiggle all around can
you push them together again you tie
them in a knot and then it goes to beat
because they're always the calf people
are feet people
it makes its way down
let's get a little bit lower
it starts with the cats next thing you
know it's down to the pinky toe by the
way do you get any weird requests online
like that
what kind of weird stuff not calf stuff
what just
weird fetish stuff yeah yeah do you want
to talk about it or not
jenny who is latino living limitless has
no problem the limit that's the limit
that is the limit right there the limit
you guys do come up with the weirdest
things to say into our dm's like
i don't know if you're just trying to
get attention or what guys sometimes
insult you
and then you respond you're like
you and then they hit on you and you're
like what what piccolo i gotcha
anyway so ladies and gentlemen that is
how you make money on youtube what a
great segue right
[Music]